there was also a big riot in Boston
Massachusetts over the weekend and this
is rather extraordinary so here is
representative congresswoman Kathleen
Clark she's Massachusetts congresswoman
and she's the Democrat whip she's a
pretty powerful Democrat and she tweeted
this out yesterday last night my
daughter was arrested in Boston
Massachusetts I love Riley and this is a
very difficult time in the cycle of joy
and pain in parenting this will be
evaluated by the legal system and I am
confident in that process
now I want to point out once again she
said that Riley is her daughter do we
have a picture of her daughter Riley
ah so that is her daughter Riley Riley
and I don't mean to be a dick about it
as I often say is a dude that is a dude
who now says that he is a chick named
Riley and the mother there the Democrat
whip is going along along for this
hallucination uh now this is interesting
because you may remember during the last
presidential campaign Joe Biden a very
confused mumbling pandering Joe Biden
went to some gay conference and he told
these people that it is not if you get
arrested it is not what is on your birth
certificate the gender on your birth
certificate that will send you to say a
male prison or a female prison it's what
gender you identify as so this is very
hopeful for Riley who will hopefully for
Riley and for that lady end up in a
female prison so many of them and so yes
and by the way in prison in prison the
determination should be that you your
sexual identity is defined by what you
say it is not what in fact the prison
says it is and in that case you should
be entitled also to OGBYN anyway you
didn't ask that question but you're not
likely to either I get I mean the man
cannot complete a sentence it's just
absolutely incredible but there you have
the president of the United States
saying whatever prison you want to go to
sure oh we arrested you for raping 20
women but now you say you're a chick
okay we'll throw you in with the women
again and then by the way these guys
continue to rape and maim and murder and
a whole bunch more so this is very
exciting in this case because Riley
hopefully will be arrested although you
know as the son or and or daughter of a
Democrat she or he is probably going to
get off on this thing that was funny in
a certain way also
um
you got it you got it uh but what this
woman Catherine Clark doesn't perhaps
understand when you when you go along
with the delusions of young people right
and don't deal with the truth straight
on and all of those things uh you're
gonna grow up you're gonna set up these
people to be in a world that makes no
sense and perhaps that is why Riley he
or she is out there doing whatever she
or he is doing on the streets of Boston
but Catherine Catherine Clark uh she was
you may remember this I think we play
this this is a couple months ago her
kids are waking up freaking out about
climate change so you just watch this
clip and note how these things are all
connected the the psychological
condition related to the violence the
nonsensical ideas related to the truth
and much more
but they've also given us a model to
become our own leaders and let me tell
you what it means to to me coming in as
a different generation I remember my
middle child waking up with nightmares
over concern around climate change all
right so Catherine's son or daughter or
son and daughter whatever it is I'm not
sure if Riley is the middle child but
she is a woman that is spreading ideas
in her home and then throughout society
as a politician that would lead children
to having nightmares about climate
change and then next thing you know your
daughter son is out on the streets of
Boston
breaking windows or doing whatever the
hell he or she is doing and then
thankfully you have a president with
dementia who wants to send them into the
opposite prison then their genitals
dictate
[Music]
foreign